I wish we coulda lured this Nazi to the
kill room like we did with Boone it's
like a walking protein shake I want to
be about more than just eating people
but I also really enjoy eating people
[Music]
spider Paul is sick and then Nazi meat
rotted you're the one who wanted to keep
living with us being around someone like
that is pretty exciting I wouldn't trade
it for the world
wild horses man you can't tame them how
much more of this do you need okay
you're immortal so unless someone puts a
spike through your head you're going to
live forever I haven't thought of that
these are the time we can spend eternity
together if you let me bite you would
you say mr. hemmond will you take this
woman to be your wife for the next
thousand years or so I just think we
should try to keep things contained
these things can snow
so my world disgusts you I got you a
present
can we acknowledge it's weird I feel
like ships getting away from us we will
be fine and one day we'll laugh about
this with our grandchildren our
grandchildren our respective
grandchildren I don't know how I'd live
without you
it's not that I don't want to be with
you it's about what I might become once
I make that decision
I can never go back
go back from feeling incredible everyday
forever no you can't every day with you
is already incredible oh my hate that
that worked
do you wanna do now I don't know why
effects may seem a little disrespectful
yeah
Hampstead okay let me just grab a
coconut water in a PowerBar
[Music]